Film Courage: How old was your dad when
he found out he had terminal cancer?
Steven Shea, Filmmaker: 48, I
think he was 48 if memory serves,
I think he was around 48 and he got diagnosed with
renal cell carcinoma which is a kidney cancer. He
removed a soft ball-sized tumor off his kidney.
He was a vegetarian, didn't drink, didn't smoke,
had a pretty healthy lifestyle but had just
gotten out of a really bad multi-year lawsuit
that caused a lot of stress which probably
probably helped out a lot I'm sure.
It was at the time they had given him eight
months and so we pushed up our wedding and
everything. He ended up lasting eight years.
He was a fighter for sure. He definitely fought
tooth and nail and so ended up lasting
about eight years on it which was great.
Film Courage: Where were you when you found out?
Steven: It's funny I actually remember exactly
where I was. I was working at the video superstore
in Orlando, Florida and he called while I was
on a shift and I remember going out and sitting
in the car on my lunch break I think and he
told me about it. I remember very vividly
and it was just kind of like Oh
okay…you know this big hit of
How did you re-evaluate your lifestyle and your
life at that point because you're kind of like
oh wow okay and rich realize really quickly
how sacred life is for sure but I remember
sitting in my 88 Suburban in that parking lot
when he called and told us and it was like oh
okay and then trying to figure out what to do from
there and when you walked back into the store did
the store look different in a way because your
perspective now everything was turned upside down
I don't know if necessarily my perspective was
completely turned upside down it was more so
of okay okay like what do we do next
what's the next step I'm definitely a very
structured kind of person so it's like all
right if I have to accomplish something
what do I have to do to get there like okay
what's next we do surgery next okay we do the
surgery remove the tumor okay then once after that
then we start chemotherapy okay so like what's the
plan to get to our goal of remission so I think
my mind was kind of more thinking that way than
thinking about oh I'm gonna go cry for an hour and
a half you know and be sad I think it was more so
about okay here we are what do we have to do to
accomplish our goal to make to make this work to
make this better which of course you only have
so much say in because it's it's a disease but
and then they started the processes and you
stuck around for another eight years it was
crazy it was cool how did that day impact his life
and how did that day impact yours he definitely
made a lot of choices and changes after that
he moved back to his home state of Louisiana
he got closer to family over there he ended up
meeting a woman Beth who they start a relationship
and she had a big farm and he started a farm which
he never had a farm before we bought him goats for
Christmas I remember her sheep sheep sheep and
goats because that was fun and she started this
farm he was a lawyer and a judge for years and
so he kind of took to this retirement he would
have to go to Houston to do chemotherapy and
through the MD Anderson Center and then after
a few of those years he started traveling you know
trying to travel to places that he hadn't been to
he tried to kind of live live the best he
could he got remarried during that to Beth
and you know lived as much as he could possibly
do but it was interesting because at the end
I have two of my sisters and I went and stayed
with them two weeks apart so we each had two
weeks with them and I had the last two weeks
and I was leaving because our short film 222 was
playing at Grauman's Chinese Theatre here in
Hollywood which was the first time i'd ever
had a movie play in Hollywood let alone at the
Grauman's Chinese Theatre it was a huge huge deal
and I was there with him for two weeks and then
I took a flight to Hollywood I met my wife she
flew out from Florida we went to this whole red
carpet had this whole incredible experience got
meetings from studios and all this different stuff
I put her back on a flight the next day because I
had set up a few days worth of meetings while I
was there and as soon as she got on the flight
and left I remember going back and I was just
hanging out just looking at the Hollywood sign
soaking everything in and then I get a call saying
he's not going to last the next day so it was
really crazy experience it was like the highest
and lowest point I think i'd ever experienced in
the same time frame and so I was like well okay
and so I went and booked a flight you know flew
back to the small town Louisiana that he was in
cancelled all my meetings cancelled everything and
and yeah he passed away the next day
and so it was a crazy whirlwind for sure
and what's what's even crazier is three months
after that my stepbrother ended up getting killed
by an accidental shooting and three months
after that my wife's mother died of cancer
so it was a very crazy year and also our son was
born right after she passed away a few months
after she passed he was born but it really going
back to the whole horror element it really lit a
fire to where it's like all right you know your
life is not guaranteed tomorrow's not guaranteed
like you've got to get going you got to make sure
that everything you're doing is impacting the
way that you want to go and to help you reach
this goal that you've set for yourself and so
you know soon after that we moved out here and
and kind of changed where we were doing things
and it's it's been great it's been wonderful but
it's that fire that kind of keeps keeps pushing
because yeah it's you never know you know and i've
had friends that have passed away that are younger
than me and stuff and even like we've had friends
pass away that you know just didn't get had their
whole chance taken from them and so like you see
that and it's like oh my gosh you know and then
your monster really goes crazy because it doesn't
want to die either and you really kind of got to
figure out what's what's the best plan you know
to get what you want and where you want to be
and once you decalculate all that I feel
like you you use your secret decoder ring
and see how the industry works and you're kind
of like okay this makes sense this makes sense
this makes sense you see what connects
the dots it does make it a little easier
but it's still pretty hard when you talked about a
passion a passionate filmmaker versus an obsessed
filmmaker do at times you check yourself because
you realize wait a minute okay i've seen somebody
who was who had a thriving career and and other
people that i've known pass away how much is
this really worth obsessing over I'm definitely a
workaholic like I like being busy I like having a
lot of stuff going on at the same time though I
get frazzled also too because of it and I have
a family I have an 11 year old son so it's trying
to find that that work-life balance of being there
for your family and then also continuing to
push to be able to get to where you want to be
and it's definitely challenging at times there's
some I mean I just went away for I was six weeks
on the road doing shoots and then had to go home
for some family stuff for a couple weeks and so
even though it was like six weeks away from home
is is tough and then you're trying to figure out
okay well i've got two hours a night of down
time that I could try to write something or try
to put something else together like while I'm
on this trip or I'm on a plane for five hours
we'll kind of get done while I'm on the plane
which most of the time you just watch movies
because you're exhausted and you don't you don't
want to do anything but it's it's trying to find
that balance and and also still enjoying things
you know you don't want to work yourself to death
to where you're 80 years old looking back being
like oh man I shouldn't have you know killed
myself writing those 37 scripts when I could
have just gone out and gone camping for the
weekend or something with my family and I think
it's important to find that to find that balance
it's not always easy to find it but you're always
trying you're always trying to find it I think
do you ever think about when you turn 48 I know
you have many years to go before that happens
oh my gosh no no I didn't think about that till
now but oh my god i've got eight years you know
for anybody who's had a parent pass away it's a
weird thing that when you become their age when
they pass away it's like this weird perspective
that I don't know maybe I'm just the only one
that thinks that no no I'm terrified no I didn't
even think about that until you just brought it up
oh well no no no I mean and just in a way of you
just see life in an interesting way and it doesn't
have to be tragic actually well interesting too my
mother was diagnosed with cancer the month after
I was born at 20. and she had hodgkin's disease
luckily which is the most curable kind of cancer
but the amount of chemotherapy she went through
in 1981 has caused a lot of damage on her body
now later in life so now she's 61 and her heart is
completely falling apart she has a lot of really
bad heart problems and her heart's way too damaged
for a transplant or anything else like that too
so now you kind of watch that side as well and
you're like okay you're trying to balance you know
everything else too with that and how much time
you have left with them and what you can do to
it's kind as a child you know you're always
trying to figure out what you can do to make
your parents proud of you right so you kind of
always have that in mind too that it's like okay
while she's still here like what can you do to
be like hey look I just did this thing that you
know maybe they're impressed by so you know they
don't know about everything so it's sometimes
it's hard to impress you like oh I got this thing
happens I don't know what that is like okay cool
but I do remember the first time my movie came
in a store and I called my dad my dad was always
he was very skeptical of everything and he was
skeptical of like everyone's skeptical the film
industry when their kids go into it because they
don't understand it they don't understand how it
works they understand there's lots of work and
you can make lots of money and there's lots of
different things about it I mean it took
my my wife's parents forever to figure out
I don't know you know they've still figured it
out like what exactly we do and how we survive but
I remember calling my dad and being like hey
the movie came out today it's like oh okay
I was like no no it's a best buy you can go
buy it and he's like what are you talking about
I'm like no it's on the shelf like go
you can go to best buy and pick it up
and he called me an hour later and he's like
you're not going to believe this your movie's
at best buy and I'm like I just told you that
like you didn't he didn't believe me I guess
and he was like I just bought every copy and I'm
like well great I know nobody else can watch it
but it's moments like that that you know you
want you want of course you want your parents
to be proud of you and and my mom's my biggest
cheerleader she's awesome she's I do a lot of
horror stuff so it's like she can't always promote
everything to her friends but at least now the new
documentary she can but yeah I mean you're always
trying to find that that approval from peers and
family and friends and everything I think do
you think it made you grow up faster I mean just
I was when I grew up in high school I was the
oldest of seven kids my dad and mom divorced and
remarried and I had three step siblings and a half
sister and so I was the oldest of seven so I felt
then that I grew up really quickly and I always
had more than one job like I started working at 16
not that I had to work I just like to work I like
to be busy so I was working at the movie theater
the video store the film commission and the tv
station all at the same time and in the keys the
keys are 180 miles long people don't realize
how big they are so I was driving around four
hours a day I drive an hour north to school
two hours down to key west to work and then an
hour home every night which is fun in l.a because
someone's like oh I don't want to drive 20 minutes
like oh i'll drive the other side of the city it
doesn't bother me two hour drive sure but it's
i forget where we were going with that that's
funny because the people I don't wanna drive
over the hill I don't wanna go over you
know laurel canyon and it's like okay
you showed up on meetings around lunch time
make the meetings at noon so you don't have
to drive in 9 a.m traffic well anytime in l.a
is there's traffic it's all pretty bad yeah
yeah what else did your dad teach you in his final
years I mean I think the things I learned most
from him in those final years was that life is not
guaranteed you know tomorrow's not guaranteed and
seeing him get more and more dehabilitated and
start once the cancer spread to his brain and
he didn't really understand like who you were all
the time or what exactly was going on all the time
I think it was really like oh man like you really
need to get your life together and figure out how
to accomplish your goals I think in entertainment
people are kind of like oh I want to be this
but they never really think about how to be that
they just assume at some point someone calls you
and you're like hey I saw this short film you
did you're awesome do you want to direct the
next avengers movie which of course would be
amazing but it doesn't really work that way
so you got to try to figure out how to get to
the point that you want and everyone's points
different I mean some people want to go and
be a makeup artist on a certain television
show or somebody wants to go and design props for
something else and there's different ways to do
everything there's no there's no right way to do
anything in the entertainment industry but there
are consistent ways that people have been become
successful so I think it's really I think one of
the things that i've learned that those last few
years was to really laser focus like exactly what
I wanted and then figure out the combination
to be able to get to there as fast as I could
he and I didn't always see eye to eye he was
definitely a person that didn't understand
a lot like he wanted me to play football I
can't play football I can't I'm like the least
athletic person ever but he played football
so it's like he wanted me to play football
though he wanted to be a writer and
his parents didn't want to do that
so he had to do what his parents wanted
and luckily he didn't force that on me but
it was just kind of a a different
mentality so you always kind of have that
besides the creature living in
your back you have this little
nagging thing that always wishes that
you had a little bit more time with him
that you could have done something that he would
have been impressed by and for me my specific one
was he was always obsessed with France with Paris
he loves France he always he went there in college
like backpacking like he always want to go back
to France and then three months after he died our
short gun in the Cannes Film Festival oh wow and
I'm like that was it that was the moment that's
the one I would have had where he would have
been like wow you actually accomplished something
and you know that was taken away and I never got
to have that moment and I feel like that will
be over my head until the day I die that one
nagging thing which is really unfortunate but
you know that's also something that's driving
you to work harder and to get there quicker and
to make it work because now I have a son and
I can encourage him to do what he wants to do
and he's awesome so he's we're literally
clones of each other like I feel terrible
for my wife she has two of us now but he is he's
amazing and what the world gives now to kids is
incredible because when I was a kid I didn't
have robotics programs in third grade like
we didn't have all these awesome programs and
website we have websites or anything to learn
from and he can do anything he wants like he's
he built his own robots at five years old and
he's gotten now he's really into molecular
biology which is interesting he's 11.
obsessed with molecular biology loves dissecting
he just dissected nine animals last year
just he loves exploring and science and everything
and it's really exciting to to go on that journey
with him and encourage him to do you know whatever
he wants and hopefully you know he won't have that
moment looming over his head at some point in life
that he didn't think he had made his father proud
and so that's a that's something else I learned
as a father now to try to work out with my son.
Are you putting off anything creative
today that you will no longer postpone?